I don't know how we did it but somehow  we are the only show to get a hold of  the audio of the phone calls no idea no  idea so why here they are a few of the  latest phone calls between vibrant Putin  and president Truong hello did you get  my gift lad they go watch yes I got it  good I just wanted to congratulate you  again on your reelection no no please it  was nothing the whole election was  rigged  wait you could rig election did you  watch the Americans or defect I heard  it's a good show did you like it I love  it  that's good don't because you and I are  actually starring in the spin-off right  now oh great  I love bigger TV can't wait to see what  happens you died tweeting on the toilet  whoa  Vlad it's me hello beaver hey Russia -  you know the ones that get smaller and  smaller and they fit inside of each  other nothing else are those right right  thanks  yeah slow day okay where do I start a  Twitter feud with young children  Oh  you